hey everyone I'm Cody Sanford and
welcome to part 2 of building a full
stack web application using view GS and
Express jeaious so if you remember on
the last part one we built a register
page which hits a slash register
endpoint on the server so in this part
too one of the things we're going to do
is actually connect to a database or
have our API connect to a database and
in this case we're gonna be using sequel
eyes which is an ORM to connect to like
sequel related databases such as like my
sequel or Postgres or sequel light a
couple people asked if we could do
MongoDB but I also I feel like you know
sequel databases are still one of the
most popular ones so I think it's more
important to learn how to use sequel vs
MongoDB and also I think the data that
we're working with is a relational which
is another reason why I think we should
be using sequel eyes to connect to a
database to store these relational
models alright so before I get started
with bringing in sequel eyes let's go
ahead and look at it really quick so
inside the sequel eyes project they have
this these Doc's defined these Doc's are
pretty good they're not the best but um
if you read through these you can get a
good understanding of how you use sequel
eyes you know how you define models how
you can use models but basically then it
in a summon up sequel eyes provides you
with data models or each model maps to a
table in a database so for instance if
you wanted to create a user model that
has a email and a password you can just
create a sequel eyes model and then will
automatically connect to whatever sequel
database such as sequel light it'll
create your tables and then create your
columns for that table and then you can
use objects inside your node or Express
server to kind of manipulate that data
or add records or remove records etc
it's kind of a fall I'm gonna cover with
the sequel eyes documentation so let's
just go ahead and get started using
sequel eyes so start off we want to
first install those dependencies so on
the right I'm going to say NPM install
save sequel eyes and then we also want
to include sequel Lite 3 and I'm gonna
do version 1 3 8
just because I ran to an issue in the
past with a newer version of sequel 93
so anyway when that stuff is done
installing it shouldn't take too long
what we can do in the meantime is we
need to first kind of get our project
set up to start using that sequel eyes
package so to start off we're going to
go ahead and pretend like we have a file
called models which is going to export a
sequel eyes object so if I do a
consequence
equals require dot slash models spell
that correctly
so basically we're assuming that there
is a models folder which has an index J
s file which returns an object that has
a sequel eyes attribute on here and what
we want to do is just go ahead and do
sequel eyes that sync which will
basically connects equalise to whatever
database that you have it configured for
and then create the tables if they don't
exist and just get everything that's set
up and ready to go and once you're done
sequel I are syncing sequel eyes to your
database we're gonna go ahead and just
start our server and to kind of make
this more useful when the server starts
just go ahead and print out a message so
we can actually know when it started so
I'll say console log server started on
port and I'll say config port and then
here I'm going to refactor this a little
bit and it's just say config port you'll
notice that we don't have anything
called config defined in this file so up
here was a Const config is equal to
require slash config slash config so the
first thing I need to do is create a new
folder called config and I'll create a
file inside that folder called config
j/s and insights config yes I want to
export something that says port 8081
so no app DOJ's can include that file
and they kind of use whatever is defined
in that couldn't fig to spin up the
application another refactor I'm going
to do before I actually start working
more into sequel eyes and defined the
models is if you notice here we have the
to find it's kind of useful if you have
a separate file where all your routes
are defined so what I'm going to do is
in the source folder I'm going to make a
new file called around Jas and that's
going to export a function and basically
what we're going to do is cut that code
out and put it inside that wraps funk
car that um routes a jeaious module save
that file and then here what we can do
is just go ahead and require that file
so I can say Const our sector to say
require routes and then I'm going to
pass it app because I remember our
routes file basically just returns the
research returns a function for us where
we can pass an app and it's going to
just go ahead and attach all the
different endpoints on to that
application or that Express application
variable alright so by this point sequel
eyes and sequel like three should be
done installing which it is so I'm gonna
go ahead and just close out of that tab
and then additionally we're seeing an
error print out because the routes file
does not have a new line at the end of
the file so I'm just going to fix that
really quick do the same thing with
config okay so it says right now can I
find module models because we haven't
even declared that yet so that leads us
to the next step of part two which I'm
going to start building up a a user
sequel eyes model so to start off let's
just go ahead and make a folder called
models and inside here I'm going to make
a new file called user J S which is
going to be my user model
so the first thing you need to do is if
you read through this equalized
documentation you can kind of figure out
how you define sequel eyes models and
we're going to do a little bit of custom
logic and linking for our models so that
we can uh kind of easily put new models
into this model folder and I'll have to
worry about importing that somewhere
else so what I'm going to do is I'm
gonna say user J s is a file which
exports a SiC a function which takes
sequel eyes and data types and then what
this is going to do is then we're going
to use sequel eyes to define so you do
sequel eyes off define a new model so
the first argument is the name of your
model and which is gonna be user and
it's gonna be used for storing user
related information so first one we want
to serve the second argument here this
is are the options or attributes that
are attached to your table or model so
the first attribute we want is email
because you know you sign up with your
email and password so say that's going
to be called email and the type is going
to be a string and then we're also going
to say that this is required to be
unique because we don't want multiple
users signing up with the same email
account and then the second attribute
we're gonna say is going to be called
password and it's also going to be a
string so at this point again user rjs
is a function which takes sequel eyes
and takes datatypes and then it's going
to return or define a user model which
we can use so now the next step is if
you remember in the apologia so we
included slash models so we need to
create a index.js file
and inside this index.js file we want to
do a couple of things first we're going
to declare a DV object which we're going
to export later on but more importantly
we first want to include a FS module
which is the nodejs way of like reading
through the file system we're going to
include the path module which is used
for kind of dealing with you know
absolute paths relatives paths or
whatever it's so we're gonna use that in
conjunction with FS we're gonna include
the sequel eyes model because we're
going to need that to actually create a
sequel eyes object and connect it to a
database we're going to include that
config file that we created earlier and
okay so at this point the first step
we're going to do is we're going to
decline I declare a sequel eyes object
so we can say a consequence is and
that's going to take in a couple of
arguments so the first argument is going
to be the database that we're connecting
to so let's just assume and config we
have something called DB database and we
can also assume that we have something
called user we have something called
password and then lastly we have
additional options that we can pass to
sequel eyes so at this point what we can
do is we can go in to that config file
and I'm going to go ahead and declare a
DB attribute which is going to have that
database it's going to have user got a
password it's going to have options so
for database we're going to load in a
couple of environment variables and fall
back to tab tracker so this is the name
of the database that we're going to use
so typically if you have like my sequel
or Postgres you create a database so
your Postgres instance is going to have
like a hundred different databases
inside of it
database has a unique name so we're say
database is equal to this environment
variable DB name or tab tracker and
we're going to use this later on when we
like deploy to a real environment but
it's good just to have this here in the
mean time and if it's not defined we're
going to fall back using a work to tab
tracker and the same thing with user
will say DB user password processing the
DB pass and that's also just going to be
tab tracker for local and then finally
we made two options there's three things
needed define so first is dialect and
that's a useful option in sequel eyes to
tell it what type of database you're
going to be connecting to so obviously
we want to set that to this equal like
when we're local
we have host and that's used for telling
sequel eyes the location of the database
that you want to connect to so in this
case we'll say localhost is the default
and then lastly we want to put storage
for sequel light and that firm it tells
you where to store your sequel light
file so I'll say tab tracker sequel
light cool so at this point we have
again a config file that declares the
port in fact I'm going to do process env
port or 8081 so we can overwrite that as
needed and then we have an attribute
called DB which has all the different
sequel eyes related configuration we
need so this if I go back to models
folder and then index ajs you can see
how this makes sense that we're just
grabbing that config and passing it to
the sequel eyes constructor here so now
the next part is we want to just go
ahead and write some short functionality
to just automatically read through all
the models in this models folder and set
it up to be useful sequel eyes so I'm
going to go ahead and do FS dot
read sync and then passenger name so
basically this is going to read through
the current directory and give us an
array of different files and then I'm
going to filter out any file that is
equivalent to index on J s so we don't
we don't want this index file but we
want every other model file and then
after we do that filter we can just say
for each file that we found we want to
go ahead and declare a model and
basically sequel eyes has a import
method where you can give it a full path
to a file and it'll go ahead and just
import that and set it up to be used
with sequel eyes so I'll go ahead and
use path join to join the der name to
the pet file and then tell sequel wise
to import it and then finally we can say
set the DB name of the model so in this
case would be DB dot user is equal to
model
and then lastly we can go ahead and
declare a couple of useful variables on
to this DB object so I'm going to
declare DB sequel eyes and capital
sequel eyes so that when we use this in
our code we have access to the sequel
eyes object we have access to the
capital sequel eyes object and then we
have access to the actual models
alrighty so at this point let's go ahead
and make sure that you know we don't
have any linting issues okay so we solve
that the server restarted itself when I
save some of the files and then it
executed this sequel command has said
create table if not exists users and
then it gave that table a couple of
columns such as email and password and
that's about it so basically sequel eyes
will create your table if it doesn't
exist and give it the columns that
you've defined in your model and that
was pretty easy to do like a lot of this
stuff like this we didn't even need to
do but it's more of a helper function
that allows us to easily add more models
down the road without having to like for
each one require it import it and set it
up and sequel eyes ok so again as a
recap we installed sequel eyes so if you
look at package shot JSON we installed
sequel eyes and sqlite3
cycle eyes is an ORM used to connecting
to SQL databases and sequel id3 is a
local instance of a sequel database
without having to go through all the
extra work of setting it up and whatnot
and then once we install those we were
going to we went ahead and created this
models folder which has a sequel eyes
model which we're going to be using for
our user accounts which has an email and
has some password and then we have this
index file which is basically used for
connecting to our database which is
going to load in a couple of
configurations which is defining our
config right here and then it's going to
go ahead and read all the files that are
in this models folder that do not equal
index on j/s and it's going to go ahead
and load them into sequel
and then we just go ahead and return
that which we can use later on so at
this point hmm we can actually start
modifying our route to use this
equalized stuff so another thing I'm
going to do let me close out of all
these tabs so we're acquiring routes
here so if I open up the routes file I
think we're done with app dot J's for a
while something that is useful and
you'll see this on a lot of frameworks
is they are going to have a folder
called controllers and a controller is
basically where you have all your
endpoints defined so inside controllers
I'm going to go ahead and create in
authentication controller J's file and
inside this file we can go ahead and
just export our model or export whatever
routes should be associated with
authentication so in this case we
obviously want to have a register route
right so if I were to do this and just
put that same function let me just get
rid of this stuff so basically I took
the same function that was defined in
routes and I put it in register but
we're only caring about the callback
function right here which is they
Express endpoint or middleware or
whatnot and then what we want to do is
in routes we can up here just go ahead
and include that so we can say Const
authentication controller it's equal to
require controllers authentication
controller so then whenever we hit this
register endpoint we can just say
authenticated authentication controller
dot register
so this is a nice way to kind of
simplify and keep everything isolated so
your controllers again are used for
declaring all your endpoints and then
your routes are for declaring your
routes that point to your controllers so
again just to make sure this works let's
go ahead and hit that register endpoint
and make sure it returns that message
and it does everything's still working
as expected
so now we can actually start
implementing some logic to kind of
create a user model and save it your
database when someone hits this register
endpoint okay so we take a step back and
just talk about what we're trying to do
or if you remember that from the front
end the user is going to pass us an
email and a password in the payload of
the JSON alright so on rec body we
should have an email and a password and
we already demonstrate that we have
email here because we're returning that
message so what we are trying to do is
we want to create a new user record in
store into our database whenever someone
hits this endpoint so first of all let's
go ahead and insert or not insert but
let's import or require that user model
that we declared so we can say cons to
user equals require dot dot model or
actually this would be ma tools because
we're going to include that index file J
s which had all the models declared as
attributes on this object so now we can
actually use that user object here that
we defined inside of our callback so
what we can do here at this point is we
could say cost user is equal to a weight
user dot create record out body now I'm
going to go ahead and get rid of this
stuff for now and of course I'm going to
use async instead of promises because it
just makes everything cleaner so
basically we want to create a user using
the body that was passed in on the
request and that will create us a new
user and if for some reason there's any
error such as you know the user our
email already exists we're gonna get
catch it inside this try-catch statement
so if we get in here we can say res dot
status is a 400 error and then go ahead
and send in some type of error message
so in this case I'll say this email
account is already in use and you've
seen that in front ends where you try to
sign up for the same website with the
same email account and I'll tell you
like you know this email account is
already news so this will be returned to
the user if this fails to run for some
reason and then if it is successful we
can just go ahead and send back that
information so I'll just go ahead and
say residents end-user to JSON to
basically send back that user object to
the client who has requested this
endpoint so go ahead and save this file
make sure that there's not any lending
issues or crashing the server seems like
everything is fine and what we can do at
this point is if I go to register and I
go and try to pass it testing at
gmail.com it should return a 200 status
with that user object that was created
all right so now this is actually inside
the sequel I'd database we actually have
a user so if I were to try to do this
again we should get that catcherror back
and says this email account has already
in use so that's pretty cool I mean we
have a server running that's connected
to a database using sequel wise we're
able to store information inside the
database at this point we can't really
grab it yet from any endpoints but we've
demonstrated that yes the data has been
changing because now we get this error
account our error message back when we
try to create an account
with the exact same email and again the
reason why that constraint is failing is
because in the model we added line 5
which is unique true saying that the
email has to be unique so it can't
already exist inside that record ok so
at this point you may say ok well if I
were to trying to pass in a bogus email
account so like 1 2 3 to this in point
it's still gonna work it's still gonna
try to create an account with that email
so another useful thing to do to have on
your back-end is validation so what
we're gonna do at this point is let's go
ahead and make or include another
framework called joy
so did npm install' save joy and joy is
a framework used for validating the
request dot body the request query or
the request dot parameters and so as an
example of how you set that up typically
in these bigger frameworks you're gonna
have like another folder kulluk policies
so I'm gonna go ahead and create a
folder called policies here and I'm
going to go ahead and create a and
authentication controller policy and
inside this file we want to kind of
create Express middleware which is going
to validate that certain requirements or
data constraints pass or fail so to
start off we'll say module dot exports
and then we're going to export the name
of the exact same method that we've used
in our controller so call it register
it's gonna be a function which takes req
resin next and what we want to do is
first we need to include that joy
framework that we just installed which
should be done by this point yep it is
so I'll close that and then we also want
to go ahead and actually that's all we
need to do right there so again we
included the joy framework we created
this module which has a
method and for now I can just say call
next and how do we actually use this
right so if you go back to routes we can
include this up here in say content
ocation controller policy it's equal to
require and I'll just say policies so
I'll go ahead and require that in and
then what we want to do is call that
policy as a middleware function before
we hit our controller so how this works
in Express is we're gonna hit this in
point and it's going to continue to go
down the list and invoke whatever
middleware that you have defined so it's
going to hit this controller policy dot
register file which is declared here and
then when this method calls next it's
going to go ahead and go to the next
line which is going to be our registry
endpoint which again is defined here so
again this is Express middleware you can
read more about it on their
documentation page and I think it'll
make more sense as we continue making
more importance down the road so what we
want to do inside this middleware
function is we need to validate that
email and password kind of match a
couple of constraints so the first
constraint we need to do is we need to
Const schema is equal to an object and
in that object we're gonna have email
we're also going to have password an
email is going to be required to be a
string and it's also going to be
required to be an email format so Joey
has a bunch of different like built-in
pre-baked validations an email as one of
them so we're saying email has to be an
email and then password we can say make
sure it's also a string and make sure it
matches a particular regex expression so
I'm just going to pass a new regex
expression and what we want to do here
is pass it character class of a through
Z capital A through Z or 0 through 9 and
course make sure it's at least 8 to 32
characters long and then go ahead and
put any money sign to end that string so
I think my I think I did that correctly
so basically again email has to be an
email address and then password has to
be a string which matches this regex
expression and again if you don't know
much about regex you should probably go
read up on regex basically we have these
classes which say everything that's
passed in has to be the character
lowercase a through Z uppercase a
through Z or 0 through 9 and it has to
be a minimum of 8 characters in a
maximum of 32 characters so after we
have this schema defined we need to
actually use it so we can say Const
error value is equal to joy not
invalidate and the first parameter you
do for validate is you need to pass it
the thing you're trying to validate so
in this case we want to validate the
request body and we want to validate it
against our schema so this will return
an error if there was an error so I'll
say if error else we just go to the next
so basically if there's no error
everything's good we just go to the
register in point and register that user
if for some reason there was an error we
need to figure out which validation
failed so I'll say switch error details
of 0 context of key so that gives us the
key that failed in this case it's gonna
be either email or password and then
we're going to have a switch case and
just check if it was email we need to do
something if it was password we got to
do something and then default do
something else
so starting off if for some reason the
email validation failed we could say res
off status of 400 and then go ahead and
send an error message saying let's say
like you must provide a valid email
address cool
and then for password similar thing but
we're gonna say this time let's just
return a little bit more information so
let's say the password provided failed
to match the following rules and then
we'll just make this HTML so we can
easily format this I can say it must
contain only the following characters
lower case upper case numerix and
that'll say roll to is it must be at
least eight characters in length and not
greater than 32 characters in length
so again if there is an error we check
if it was an email error and we can send
back you must provide a valid email
address we check if as a password error
and say you know the password has to
match these rules and then otherwise we
can just say like I don't know resident
status of 400 send an error saying like
invalid registration information
so that should make sense let's just
again do a recap we included the joy
framework which is used for validating
different things in express and then we
created a module which has a register
method which is an Express middleware
which takes a wreck a res and a next and
again wreck is the request that comes in
res is what you use to send something
back and next is what you call to invoke
the next thing in the routes path and
then we declared a schema which says
emails must have an email structure
passwords must match this Fredericks we
validate the req body against the schema
here we check the error we check the key
of the error and return different error
messages depending on what failed and
then after that everything was good we
just go ahead and call next so at this
point I'll go ahead and save that file
and I'll double check to make sure that
we don't have issues so on the routes we
have no trailing spaces I'm go to the
routes file
cool all right so now at this point
let's go ahead and test out that the
policy is working as expected and to do
that we can again go back to postman and
we can try to pass in bogus data so
we're say passages testing it sends back
in here you must provide a valid email
address with a 400 bad request response
and so if I were to give it a good email
address and try to send it's gonna say
the password provided failed to match
the following rules so cool that's
working if I go to 7 & 8 and send that
it says this email account is already in
use so I'll change that and see what
happens
so boom we were allowed to create a 1 to
3 at gmail.com with the password 1 2 3 4
5 6 7 8 and it returns us back the exact
user that has been created all right so
now at this point we have a pretty good
setup for registering a user into our
database and we have policies that kind
of return errors so that the user knows
what exactly is required we also need to
at some point hash the password because
you're not supposed to be saving you
know raw passwords into your database
what we can kind of cover that in a
second so let's go ahead and move to the
UI again so if I go back to that
register component up here just a recap
we had an input for email and input for
password and we had a button to register
ok so now that the backend is returning
different error codes and messages we
want to kind of display that in our user
interface so what we can do is if we
want to catch the error let's return to
B go ahead and just wrap this in a
try-catch so if for whatever reason
authentication service fails to return
or fails to for whatever sorry rephrase
that for whatever reason an
authentication service the endpoint
returns a status other than like 200 or
whatnot where you can catch that error
here and we go ahead and say this out
error is able to
I'm gonna change this to response
actually not say err so I'll say era dot
response data dot error and this is
basically what is returned from Axios
and then error is going to be that
message that we've defined and of course
if we're going to try to access this on
error we need to define it in data oops
and then last thing we need to have
print that out so up here if I above the
button I could just do div and I guess a
V HTML is equal to error I can just
close up close that off here and again
put a break I'm also going to say that
this is going to be a class of error so
down in the style I can say error is
equal to color of red so I were to save
this file now and then try to register
some bogus data we get you must provide
two valid email address change to a
gmail comm the password you provided
failed to match the following rules it
seems like that kind of truncated some
of the data so maybe this isn't like big
enough let me just double check what's
going on here
hmm
because it looks like it's returning
okay so in my my back and you see
there's a little missing a carrot here
so let me just go back to my back-end
code really quick to my authentication
controller actually I'll go to my policy
and I'll change that to that now if I
try to hit the endpoint again boom okay
so we get the actual full error message
now cool so again as a recap
I don't really explain the view
components before but basically every
dot view file is separated into three
sections you have to go template which
is used to define your HTML template and
then inside your HTML you can have
special attributes like be model or be
HTML take technically anything that has
a V - is they view specific attribute
and that's used to kind of bind to your
script tag down here which is the second
part that every top view component has
and the script is basically an object
that has a different lots of different
methods on it so data is the data that
you can bind to way in one way to your
template and then methods would be any
type of method that you want to be able
to access from your template and there's
a couple of others which we'll cover in
the future but it's just for now we just
focus on those two and again the last
one is your style section which is going
to be in this case scoped so any Styles
you declare here will not affect
anything else on your few application
assuming that you have scoped so dot
error will only work for this template
so again everything in view is really
like compartmentalized and isolated so
it's really nice let's try to think and
again here's an example at clique means
whenever the button fires a click event
call the register method which is what
you saw down in here that's how we're
calling register Sarge's a little bit
more information about the view
component that I don't think I've really
talked about in part one I kind of just
started doing stuff without talking but
hopefully by now that kind of makes more
sense
all right so for I think the last thing
I'm gonna do in this part 2 video is I
want to kind of bring in a new project
inside the front-end to a lot of see
easily style and kind of do layouts so
there's a there's a project called
beautify which is a framework that you
can be used to build like material
design apps mm-hmm so again their
documentation is pretty good here on the
left it has like you know all the
components you can use so if I wanted to
do like a grid list or a form they give
you examples of how you do it you can go
and check out their code here they give
you a template I think you can see the
code somewhere maybe not let me find a
different one data tables here we go so
again they give me an example of a data
table you can go here and view the
source code what you get is the template
and they give you the script here mm-hmm
so again beautify is just a framework
that's used for building really nice
material design apps so we feed it feel
free to check it out and that's what
we're gonna be using so what we want to
do to include this in our application as
we first want to go over to again our
terminal and go to our client and we
want to MPM install a couple of things
so first of all we want to include
beautify and I think actually that's the
only thing we need to include is just
beautify okay so now that that is done
installing we can just go back to our UI
and we want to include it so if we go to
our main DOJ's file here up here we can
just say import view to Phi from
beautify and then we also want to import
the style sheet so I'll say beautify
dist beautify min CSS and then to kind
of enable that we can say view use of
ufi
go ahead and save that and hopefully
assuming I didn't forget anything that
should kind of load in the project so
now we have the beautifying in the
beautify CSS ready to go
so let's go ahead and try to style this
there's some there's a cup of the design
I kind of like doing is putting stuff in
panels with like a drop shadow I'm not
really a style or a designer so feel
free to kick me or give me feedback so
what I'm gonna do here is I'm gonna go
to the register that view file here and
beautify gives you the ability to kind
of like change up your layout so they
give you something called like be layout
you can pass it like a column layout so
I'll do P layout and this is pretty much
um like flex box so this is a be like a
flex grid or whatever and in here we can
do V flex which is going to be a flex
item and then you can change it kind of
like a bootstrap where you can change it
depending on the size of the screen we
can say for small screens we want to
offset it three and then just make it a
width of six and then in here we can say
mmm let's make a div and then the
beautify CSS gives you a couple of pre
baked CSS so we can give it a elevation
of two and a white that's going to make
like a white panel with a little bit of
box shadow or drop shadow another thing
we can get from using beautify is a V
toolbar so this a B toolbar I'll pass it
a flat and a dense attributes I'll give
it a class of Sian
I'll give it a tributo dark so that it
turns the text white and then inside the
toolbar again this is all in the
beautify examples so if you just want to
go and copy and paste from there
examples you can do that too
so let me just make sure I got this all
right
basically I can copy this code out and
put it underneath here grab this in the
div in case we need some padding and it
also beautify get to a couple of classes
so I can do like padding left is for
padding right for padding top to padding
bottom of to so make sure all these line
up kind of running out of energy so I
might wrap this up pretty soon so
hopefully if I save this it should be a
styled panel with register and then we
have our email account and we have our
password here and then we have a
register button in the button we can
actually change from button to mething V
button so if I were to do B BTN
give it a class of cyan should changes
to a register button so that's I think
good enough for right now we can come
back and make this a lot nicer looking
but I'm kind of running out of energy so
stay tuned for part three and again as a
recap we included the beautify project
which again you can find the docs here
and beautify Jas comm they have a bunch
of different components and styles that
are pre baked it's really awesome
library so check it out and then we use
a unify that kind of style this register
panel and I think part three we can just
try to fix up the styling and do more by
adding like a header or side nav or
something like that alright thanks for
watching and stay tuned for part three
should be coming in a couple days
hopefully thanks for watching